en el vídeo anterior sobre la respuesta
al escalón vimos la ecuación diferencial
que describe al circuito y encontramos
que es una ecuación no homogénea aquí
vamos a continuar con la estrategia de
resolverla con la respuesta natural y la
respuesta forzada aquí tenemos dos
copias de nuestro circuito en el de
arriba vamos a resolver la respuesta
natural y usaremos el de abajo para
resolver la respuesta forzada comencemos
con la respuesta natural para resolverla
tenemos nuestras condiciones iniciales
del circuito original con q y b 0 en el
capacitor vamos a dibujarlas aquí
tenemos la carga q ibex 0 en el
capacitor otra cosa que hicimos fue
poner en cero nuestras entradas para la
respuesta natural como lo hacemos aquí
la entrada es nuestra fuente de voltaje
así que vamos a quitarla es lo que
hacemos con la superposición cuando
quitamos la fuente de voltaje hacemos
que el voltaje de entrada sea cero
que es como si tuviéramos o crearemos un
cortocircuito así que para la respuesta
natural vamos a quitar la fuente de
voltaje y la vamos a reemplazar por un
cortocircuito así ahora este circuito es
idéntico al que usamos cuando calculamos
la respuesta natural y si aún no han
visto este vídeo sobre la respuesta
natural este es un muy buen momento para
que lo hagan lo que voy a hacer es
escribir la respuesta que obtuvimos aquí
tendremos el más a quien menos y a esto
lo llamaremos b natural y va a ser igual
a k natural por el ala menos t entre
porsche esta es la respuesta natural de
un circuito rc así que lo resaltamos
para recordarlo vamos a dejar esta
constante aquí y más adelante veremos a
que es igual ahora veamos cuál es la
respuesta forzada para este circuito
recordemos que las condiciones iniciales
son iguales a 0 para la respuesta
forzada es
tanto el voltaje inicial como la carga
en el capacitor son iguales a cero así
que aquí escribo cero esto significa
poner las cantidades iniciales a cero en
este caso si vamos a usar las entradas y
nuestra entrada es igual a bs y en
particular vamos a resolver nuestra
respuesta forzada después de que el
tiempo haya sido igual a cero lo que
significa que la entrada es de mayúscula
s recordemos que aquí tratamos de
resolver la ecuación diferencial que
vimos anteriormente que es c dvd t y voy
a ponerle un subíndice f aquí para
indicar que es la respuesta forzada + 1
/ r
bf por df igual a 1 / r por bs aquí
pongo b mayúscula s porque estamos
tratando de resolver esto para esta
condición inicial esta es nuestra
ecuación diferencial para la respuesta
forzada y para resolverla haremos algo
similar a lo que hicimos para resolver
la respuesta natural proponer una
solución para b efe sustituirla en esta
ecuación diferencial no homogénea y ver
si funciona una buena propuesta sería
encontrar algo que sea muy similar a la
entrada una función que luzca como bs y
como luce bs si vemos aquí bs luce como
una constante así que vamos a decir que
la respuesta forzada luce como una
constante que llamaremos acá y vamos a
probar nuestra propuesta sustituyendo la
aquí en la ecuación diferencial por lo
que vamos a hacer lo que es igual a d
efe / dt + 1 / r
efe igual a 1 / r v s y aquí hay algo
interesante que sucede a continuación
cuál es la derivada de una constante con
respecto al tiempo es 0 así que el
término principal de nuestra ecuación
diferencial se vuelve 0 y ahora nos
quedamos con café por 1 entre r igual a
de s por 1 entre r lo cual hace que bs
sea igual acá efe nuestra respuesta
forzada de f es igual a bs ahora ya
tenemos tanto nuestra respuesta natural
como nuestra respuesta forzada que es la
constante de s
estamos listos para calcular la
respuesta total que llamaremos b t
mayúscula
es igual a la respuesta natural más la
respuesta forzada ya que estamos usando
el principio de superposición de t es
igual a kn una constante por el ala
menos t / rc más la respuesta forzada
que es bs nos estamos acercando lo único
que nos falta es encontrar esta
constante kn que es el factor de
ganancia que está frente a la
exponencial de la respuesta natural
podemos conocer su valor si conocemos
esto bs que si conocemos y si conocemos
a 20 en cierto momento así podríamos
sustituir dichos valores aquí el de bt y
t uno de los valores del tiempo más
conveniente es a usar aquí es cero si
decimos que t es igual a cero b total
cuando te es cero va a ser
y volvamos a lo que teníamos al
principio quitemos esto que era para dar
respuesta forzada y que no vamos a
ocupar ahorita y ahora tenemos el
circuito completo
recordemos que el voltaje inicial aquí
era de 0 que es este valor de aquí justo
antes de t igual a cero éste era el
voltaje en el capacitor así que lo
ponemos aquí regresemos a nuestra
solución total y sustituyamos estos
valores de igual a cero ivette e iguala
de cero lo que nos da de cero igual a kn
por la menos cero entre el reporte más
bs despejamos kn lo que nos da acá en es
igual a él a la cero es uno quedando kn
más bs de este lado el despeje nos da de
cero menos bs esto es nuestra carne
la respuesta total es de te iguala de
cero - bs por el ala menos de entre
reporte más
bs esta es la respuesta total de nuestro
circuito la resolvimos en dos pasos
primero la respuesta natural y después
la respuesta forzada luego la sumamos y
finalmente calculamos la constante en el
siguiente vídeo haremos un ejemplo
explícito en donde tendremos valores
para r para c y para el escalón y
veremos como luce la respuesta total